Speaker 1: Fox News's Sean HANNITY thought
that he would bring on Democratic California
Governor Gavin Newsom and make them look dumb
by getting him to talk about Biden and getting
him to talk about California.
And Gavin Newsom proved everything I have
been saying about him for the last several
months.
You know, Gavin Newsom is not the most progressive.
But Gavin Newsom strikes exactly the right
tone, demeanor and temperament that the Democratic
Party could use more of.
This is a guy who, every time I see him interviewed,
proves that he is a serious potential future
contender for the Democratic presidential
nomination.
Now, would he be attacked for being the liberal
California woke up?
Yeah, he would.
Would he have answers to those claims?
He would look at this interview and look at
how Newsom crushes Sean HANNITY on his own
show, starting here with economic issues.
This is a clinic visit.
When you have trainings done of Democratic
candidates.
This is what you need to be showing our president.
Speaker 3: I have great confidence in his.
I don't want him to fail to accomplish.
I think his policies are failing.
Chip SAC Science Act.
You pose that.
I will tell you on every measure from the
economy, inflation, borders, energy, national
security, he's missing in action.
Let's talk about them in order.
Let's hang on.
Okay.
But I want to challenge the premise.
Speaker 1: HANNITY wants to list them, but
he doesn't want to go through one by one.
Typical.
Speaker 3: And the economy, 13.1 million jobs.
He's created more.
These are post-COVID jobs.
You know that.
That's an artificial number.
No, no.
Then let me just let me say I'll take this
as an as an opportunity to engage civilians.
Okay.
Fair point.
Your president, Donald Trump, lost 2.6 million
jobs during his four years.
We've created 13.1.
May find you can maintain a Kolbert frame.
How about the fact that Joe Biden's created
more jobs, six times more jobs than the previous
three Republican President, Joe Biden?
Are you going to tell me that the average
family where we have two thirds of Americans
now living paycheck to paycheck, it was 70%
under Trump?
Speaker 1: That's just frickin brilliant guys,
guys that this is exact.
They love to cite these numbers.
Two thirds of families are now paycheck to
paycheck.
Of course, it's not actually two thirds.
Two thirds would be 66.6%.
The number is actually in the low sixties.
So HANNITY rounds up and Newsom points out
that number is down like seven points from
when Trump was president.
This is exactly how you have to fight these
guys.
Speaker 3: That was 77% under Donald Trump,
living paycheck, the lowest unemployment rate
for every demographic.
Speaker 1: And they are even lower now that.
Speaker 3: We have the lowest unemployment.
And you and I are living with the lowest unemployment
we have in our lifetime in California.
Every demographic in the economy, like unemployment's
record low under Joe Biden.
Okay.
We had a historic low after historic low under
Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: And it is even better now.
This is how you don't back down from these
bullies.
Two of the best messaging folks.
I'm talking from a communications standpoint
right now.
Okay.
We're not doing a policy analysis are on the
left are Gavin Newsom and Pete Boudette, Judge.
Okay.
This is how you have to fight these people
now.
Obviously, this alone won't win you elections.
I'm not delusional, but this is how you do
it.
Here is the topic of inflation and Newsom
is just barreling through HANNITY question.
Speaker 3: I'm answering the ones in order
to run up the economy.
On the economy, let's talk about the economy.
Give him an inflation stubborn around the
globe.
Let's let's put let's talk about inflation
is down 40% since last summer, months in a
row, 4.9%.
Speaker 1: He was just and by the way, now
down to 4%.
This interview was from last night.
So that's why they don't have that data yet.
Speaker 3: U.K. prime minister, it's 6.9%.
Is that because of Biden's?
I think his economic and energy policy directly
impacted the U.K. is inflation.
No, I am for the fact that France is 5.5%
of Germany's.
It's not inflation.
We're moving in the right direction, folks.
Speaker 1: He's steamrolling him this.
It's stunning.
HANNITY is HANNITY is lost control and he
doesn't have the facts on his hand.
Speaker 3: On the issue of the border security
of heritage, 1.4% inflation.
It went up to 40 year high, a 40 year high.
BILLY globally, because you just brought up
you were making an excuse for Trump's dismal
jobs record.
Brady takeover.
It wasn't a year ago its relationship to inflation.
Speaker 1: This is folks this is this is textbook.
HANNITY wants to have it both ways.
Yes, Trump lost 2.6 million jobs, but that
was because of COVID.
But what about high end?
Nation under Biden.
Well, hold on.
That's globally because of COVID.
Oh, no, then it's not.
Then COVID isn't the explanation.
Newsom is almost perfect on this.
HANNITY polls the Biden's weak thing.
Here is.
Speaker 3: Newsom I think he's a man of decency
and character.
I'm really proud of the president, proud of
what he's accomplished, strong enough to be
president.
That's strong enough going about what he just
did, the McCarthy Iran circus, look at the
vote card and just got I want to go to for
exactly.
Kevin got played by the president United States.
I'm for results.
Speaker 1: Did you did you see what just happened?
Speaker 2: Did you see that?
Speaker 1: HANNITY is agreeing with Newsom.
Newsom's making the argument, if Biden is
so weak, how did he have McCarthy wrapped
around his finger and got McCarthy to do exactly
what he wanted?
And HANNITY goes, I wouldn't have voted for
that bill that McCarthy voted for.
That's the point.
If Biden is so weak, how did he perfectly
engineer McCarthy into doing what he wanted
him to do here?
Just a couple more of these.
And this.
We could do this all day.
Here's Newsom explaining, hey, you know, California
actually works pretty well.
Yeah, things are expensive because people
want to go there.
It's called supply and demand.
But California is working pretty damn well.
Speaker 3: In 2021, California, 7.8% of GDP,
GDP growth in this country, one of the fastest
growing economies anywhere on planet Earth.
This state continues to be the tempo of the
American economy.
25.6% of all American jobs came from this
state in April.
In the last two fiscal years, we enjoyed $177.7
billion in operating surpluses.
We're on our way to be the fourth largest
economy.
Eat your heart out.
Germany in the world, number one in R&D, venture
capital.
More scientists, researchers, more Nobel laureates,
more patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America, with all due respect
for doesn't even come close.
Eat your heart out of Texas.
California continues to be the dominant economic
engine for them.
I promised you before this interview I would
let you give full answers.
That's a full answer thing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it is.
And I mean, when you can't when you can't
argue the facts.
HANNITY has no choice but to say thank you
for at least answering the questions.
And here lastly, is he.
NEWSOM just humiliating Ron DeSantis?
Speaker 3: They were told they had jobs.
They told they were going to get certain court
dates changed.
They were dropped off, they knocked on the
door and they left.
And it was not coordinated.
I mean, what kind of faith tradition ever
since there is a video, even as a show of
the people getting on the because they were
all lied to and told and they were being taken
care of, everything's going to be great.
I would be proud and happy.
And then because by the way, I have the RFP,
because they landed in your sanctuary state,
you're going to take care of them.
They should be happy.
Look.
Well, we'll deal with the big Come on.
This is California.
I know where we're all in this way.
The fourth largest economy, the work we can
handle.
Of course, You got this.
Okay.
I'm a border state.
Ron DeSantis is not.
I know he's desperate to get in on the act
now because a lot of people flock.
Donald Trump is going to clean.
Is it There is a Joe Biden.
DeSantis was a belly flop.
It will clean his clock.
He don't have a crystal ball.
And he set this up months ago by doing an
RFP.
I have the contractor, my qualified hire,
saying he was going to send people to California.
This is a stunt.
It's embarrassing, pathetic.
I just don't.
I think he did the right thing.
His state's not a sanctuary state, Art.
Speaker 1: She did the right thing by by flying
migrants around, even though I can't explain
why.
Folks, this is a formidable political force.
And this is not about cheerleading Newsom
as the epitome of the progressive candidate.
This is about a model for the next generation
democratic movement that better knows how
to deal with these would be bullies.
If you didn't know any better, you'd think
that was Gavin Newsom's show and that he was
allowing HANNITY to say a few things, things
which, by the way, didn't make a lot of sense.
Excellent job
by Gavin Newsom